avec nous marianne clamant dont avocate
spécialisée en droit du travail chez
langlois avocat bonsoir bonsoir 29
octobre donc pour la vaccination
obligatoire est ce que ce délai est trop
court
pas si sûr que ça donne ça donne le ton
et donc les employés vont devoir de
trouver le comment ceux qui sont non
vaccinés le commun qui vont faire face à
cette nouvelle exigence la cessoie que
ça à boîte le ton qui veut reprendre ça
crée des répercussions dans divers
milieux
oui s'en occupe donc une date 29 octobre
l'autre date c'est 15 novembre
suspension sans salaire
pour les non vaccinés pour ceux qui ne
veulent pas s que des bases solides pour
le gouvernement pour dire pour justifier
qu'on puisse aller jusqu'à suspendre
sans salaire mais c'est sûr qu'il va y
avoir des contestations devant les
tribunaux on est dans du droit nouveau
parce que j'avais une situation comme
celle là avec une vaccination
obligatoire on est complètement dans une
nouvelle nouvelle serre maintenant
j'espère que le gouvernement en fait ses
devoirs et s'est assuré d'avoir
suffisamment de données expliquant
pourquoi c'était nécessaire d'aller
jusque-là et d'imposer la vaccination
obligatoire alors qu'on sait que c'est
une violation du droit à l'intégrité
contre la personne donc à ne pas son
consentement en vue de garder son emploi
donc c'est sûr que ça soulève multiples
questions de droit et quand on parle de
co2 de suspension ou de congés sans
solde il faut savoir qu'en vertu des
conventions collectives ou en vertu du
droit applicable après un certain qu'à
ça devient de fin d'emploi permanents et
non ça va ouvrir là qu une cause de
congédiement sans cause juste et
suffisante donc on peut s'attendre à ce
qu'il ya beaucoup de plaintes en disant
ce n'est pas une cause juste pour me
congédier les faits que j'ai fait le
choix de ne pas vacciner mais quand le
premier ministre du canada dit plus de
80 % des gens sont doublement vacciner
ça veut donc dire que de 15 à 20 % ne
sont pas parmi les fonctionnaires donc
est-ce que ça ouvre la voie à une vague
de contestation et a beaucoup de travail
pour les avocats
comme humblement mais c'est sûr que mon
certains sont syndiqués sont pas tous
que tout le temps les mêmes recours le
qui s'applique le certains devront dans
les dom à l'elysée rires par contre il y
aussi la loi canadienne des droits des
droits de la personne on peut s'attendre
qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de
contestations à ce niveau là maintenant
et j'imagine comme je vous dis qu'ils
ont fait leurs devoirs qui sont allés
chercher documentation pour démontrer
pourquoi s'est-elle nécessaire d'aller
jusque là parce que le repos le droit du
travail continue de s'appliquer même si
on est en situation de pandémie et donc
est ce qu'elle est ce que les
travailleurs ont encore des arguments
pour défendre leur droit de continuer de
travailler sans être vaccinés mais
prenons par exemple un employé en
télétravail qui réussit très bien à
fournir garder la même productivité
depuis le début de la pandémie pourquoi
est-ce que du jour au lendemain quand
télétravail son clubbing tu peux
continuer en télétravail on l'oublié
jasper vacciner
là est toute la question est là et qu'on
lui demande
comme jeudi le d'aller à l'encontre de
son droit à l'intégrité à sa vie privée
parce que c'est un choix personnel et
qu'on ne lui permet pas d'avoir un
consentement éclairé savons
c'est ce que ça soulève multiples
questions ça soulève certainement des
questions parce que faut-il le souligner
à grands traits les personnes qui sont
en télétravail et en télétravail tout le
temps doivent aussi être obligatoirement
vaccinez vous pensez qu'ils en cause la
défendre pour ces personnes là qui ne
voudrait pas avoir cette obligation
ben si c'est qu'en faites vous oui la
nécessité d'aller jusque là pour ces
travailleurs leur et comme il y aura des
débats jeudi qui seront faits et comme
dépendamment du recours évidemment le
débo épaules mais maintenant c'est sûr
qu'il ya des certains secteurs de la
fonction fédérale où on n'avait pas le
choix d'aller là parce qu'il y avait
trop de comptes à coup on avait des
bains de foule et donc à ce moment là
c'est pour la sécurité et se sont plus
facile à justifier pourquoi quand on a
décidé d'aller vers la vaccination
obligatoire mélo chance ou si c'est
toutes les effets parce qu'on dit on
parle aussi des sociétés de la couronne
on parle aussi de d'autres toutes les
entreprises fédérales et veulent pas
c'est l'une des conséquences sont toutes
les entreprises qui sont fournisseurs de
ces entreprises le fédéral qu'elle soit
provincial ou fédéral parce que ces
entreprises là à ce moment le doivent
respecter la politique mais a mis sur
pied par les sociétés fade et fédérales
comme quoi que le vaccin est dorénavant
obligatoire et ça aussi ça soulève
énorme bonne question parce qu'au niveau
provincial on n'aura pas cette pièce de
législation le pour obliger la
vaccination parce que par exemple
beaucoup d'entités sous-traitent par
exemple l'entretien ou les service de
cafétéria
donc ses sous traitants love sont
couverts également par l'obligation
vaccinale
by cc c'est là qu'on voit parce qu'elle
veut pas si on oblige nos employés comme
expliquer qu'on a déjà qu'ils côtoient
nos envoyés puis on leur laisse la
chance de ne pas être vaccinés ça ne
fait pas de sens alors l'oeuvre pose la
question et au niveau provincial à
l'heure actuelle ben on n'a pas de
décrire où on n'a pas de recommandation
de la santé publique qui permet de le
soutenir la vaccination obligatoire un
mot sur le droit des voyageurs est ce
que est ce que peuvent dire qu'on brême
leur liberté de mouvement au canada en
exigeant la vaccination pour voyager
avec via rail ou air canada c'est pas
une liberté fondamentale comme le droit
à l'intégrité et tout donc je pense que
les arguments sont moins forts pour les
voyages en certainement que des employés
et qui rouvre pas certains vont perdre
leur gagne pain donc les conséquences
sont graves et l'autre chose aussi
l'argument c'est toujours que si la
personne n'est pas d'accord pour prendre
l'avion d'être vaccinée elle est
toujours une option allait prendre la
voiture notre bus où nous avons des
moyens de transport des vélos marché
par exemple m marianne plamondon merci
beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d